M it's
God it's
God but I mean the Bible says a man that
is a heretic reject man so you got so
then why don't you reject yourselves why
am I going to reject something teach man
you're you're you're teaching heretical
scripture there this is the book of
second thalon you're teaching heretical
scripture this is the book of second
Thessalonians 2:3 so how how's it a
waste of time if we're doing this this
is the book of second Thessalonians 2:3
let no man deceive you by any means how
is it a waste of time let no man deceive
you by any means for that day shall not
come except they come and falling away
first and that happen so what's the
decep the falling away first is called
the apostasy apostasia but you guys have
apost from the Bible and that man of sin
be revealed the son of predition the man
of sin shall be and you guys don't even
want to have a discussion on this uh uh
give me your scripture the last time we
went over the scriptures you guys didn't
have answers why is that
her what about the salvation of the
Gentiles why don't you guys don't talk
about that you guys teach us salvation
by race and not by Grace that's that's
heretical to the Bible I think that's uh
the third chapter I dude you don't got
to be afraid of what we talking about
man afraid man we out here to have no
debates you don't believe what we
believe man so so but what are you out
here for what are y here for people
aren't your
people ar your people you go read that
one more time didn't you tell me last
time I was one of you you said you don't
believe right you said you're not but
you said I'm one of you but but do you
believe that you're an Israelite it
doesn't matter if I it doesn't matter
it's about the scripture 3: 10 the
scripture says that I'm I'm a Jew in
regardless second ad Mission rejected
that's Romans Chapter 2 so hey get
another scripture where it says uh
Romans chap 2 get Romans where it says
uh rejected silver are they get Romans
Chapter 2 where it says that you're
you're a Jew in you got your own Bible
yeah I could I could get it up bring it
you don't want to read it you don't want
to read it for us this is edify the
people 6 verse 30 reprobate silver do
you see how these guys silver do you
guys do you guys see how they're her
heretical do you guys see how they put
on their clothes they come out with the
posters but they don't want to talk they
want to come out with the scriptures but
they want to say that they're bold but
they can't even have a conversation
about the scriptures look at these dudes
E I think that's they come out here with
their blankets and their curtains on
patches and all this kind of stuff but
they have no def of the scriptures the
Bible says give an answer for what you
believe right 2 ver 5 and they whether
they will hear it says give an answer
right be ready to give an answer right
they are let's get it out people are
rebellious man let's get let's get the
scripture out let's see if they if they
going with the scripture man there you
go man so hey hey the prophets were out
here let's see if they going with the
scripture man they have hey uh get that
uh isah let's see let's see that we we
going to get this uh first first Peter
we're going to get this first Peter 3
man hey man you go go over there man
just wel I'm going to be right here cuz
I want to talk to you guys can you step
back a little bit please yeah I got
you there we
go
uh you told me that you told me to get
out the scripture you wanted me to get
out the scripture so I'm going read it
ver and therefore will the this is First
Peter bro get that scripture where it
say this is First Peter do not speak in
the mid chapter
three it says but in your hearts honor
Christ the Lord Is Holy always being
prepared to make a defense show me the
verse show me the verse where it says
don't read with your head on can you
show me the
verse show me the verse where it says do
not read the Bible with your hat on this
is the book of First Corinth precept
upon precept the book of First
Corinthians line line four every man
praying or prophesying having his head
cover dishonor his head what does this
have to do with reading the Bible you
said reading the Bible with your head on
part of prophesying and reading man
where does it say that prophesy you read
where does it say that read it one more
time this is the book of 1 Corinthians
11: 4 every man praying or prophesying
having his head covered dishonor his
head do it read in church you're
dishonoring your head wait wait where
are we in church right now this is
church this is church no this ain't
Church who said this is the church we're
not two or three that are GA the word
church means the Assembly of the
Israelites no it doesn't no it doesn't
at all it's the Assembly of the
Believers you see that's what I'm saying
I asked you to prove something you can't
even prove it with the scripture Isaiah
38 so let me finish reading the
scripture man Isaiah 308 let me finish
reading this going and will the Lord
wait it says always being prepared to
give an answer give a defense to anyone
who asks you for the reason of your
faith so why can't you guys give a
defense why can't you give a defense I'm
a fellow Israelite ready to discuss the
scriptures with you guys Paul talked to
not discussing you trying to debate
we're not here well no so what did Paul
do in the synagogues just wasting your
time what did Paul do in the synagogues
just wasting your time did Paul go and
confound the his fellow Israelites
trying to get from us man we want a a
Biblical conversation we don't want to
but why not cuz I said so see but that's
the thing now you're going against the
scripture oh why where is it you're
going against because you're not ready
to give a defense but you just got Titus
man man there a heretic you don't
believe prove that I'm you got to prove
that I'm a heretic you you don't believe
what we teach but you don't believe that
you're isite prove that what you're
teaching is
true prove that what you're teaching is
true eclesiastes 5 ver hey this is Nega
Behavior right here man Nega Behavior oh
look at this guys goes to this is [__]
Behavior he says to sacrifice a yeah
sacrifice of he said he said this is
this is [__] Behavior they have no
answer for what they believe they can't
give a defense with the scripture and so
what they got to do is now they got to
call me a [__] because they have no
answer for the scripture they got no
scripture give an answer and give a
defense for your faith and when you
can't do it they shrivel because these
are Heretics that have no answer the
book of no answer at all the pow is in
Christ let's get another scripture with
thy mouth let not thy heart be Hasty to
he said you don't believe you're an
Israelite let's see what an Israelite
actually is inen and thou upon Earth
what's an Israelite remember when Sahar
said to uh [__] call the cops let's
go ahead let's let's see what let's see
what a Jew is but a Jew is one inwardly
one inwardly right the Jews one inly
right wasting his time that's what I
thought yeah
you acting like a gentile right now but
a Jew is one
inwardly and circumcision is a matter of
the heart y'all ain't been circumcised
man y'all are some uncircumcised
Philistines your hearts ain't been
circumcised you ain't been saved you
have the you don't have the Holy Spirit
you're preaching out of ignorance and
heresy and you need to repent of your
heresy and turn to the gospel stop stop
copying this weakness Israelites Wicked
man these weak teachings of demons that
you guys follow it got y'all coward in
in front of one one [__] y'all can't
even answer one [__] y'all can't answer
one [__] are you raising your voice man
y'all can't I come talk to I'm just
talking to you I'm just making sure you
can hear me y'all can't y'all can't
answer me why did why did why did you
raise your voice when you was reading
you see me cuz we're reading well I was
I was talking to you Foundation of
another man I was I was talking to you
but no no you're you're on my you're on
the foundation right here doing our own
why would I CU we said so walk I I'm not
going to walk away I'm not going to I'm
going to give you the scripture you're
scared of the scripture walk away man
why is he scared why is your boy scared
of the scripture walk away man you're
afraid of the scripture let's get
another scripture let's see it says by
the spirit not the letter this is the
book of First MTH his praise is not for
man but from God and those days when
they're out of Israel this is how it is
who pers many saying let us go and make
a c keep the camera rolling man that are
round about us keep
rollart from them you guys see this
these guys do not have an answer for
their faith oh man ain't nobody watching
anyway a even got nobody watching who
they talk they talking about educating
the people ain't got nobody watching
it's live with nobody zero zero views
what maybe I should start my live stream
maybe they'll get some people to watch
huh let's let's start our live stream
there what Black Culture teaches you man
how to be a real [__] right right keep
look at you look at you stuttering over
here cuz you don't know the scripture
let's get some more man real [__] here
with let's get some more scripture man
this what we call we call it uncle let's
get some more scripture man uncle rers
right here man yeah I bet with the Enemy
with I bet get some viewers before you
start talking get some viewers first get
some viewers first let see how tough you
are when the cameras are off get some
why why why would I turn the cameras off
you need to be exposed you're being
exposed as the devil that you are you're
a devil what does the word devil mean uh
you somebody who's an adversary Satan an
enemy of God that's what you are right
[__] you're going against the
gospel why why are you why are you so
hateful Accord according to the
scripture the Lord hates you but Y show
me where the Lord hates me he hates you
man show me that I going to show you
pret
exactly you can't show me nothing man
you got confounded last time I spoke to
you you're confounded now you can't show
me nothing that you say which is why you
want me to leave which is why you're
calling me out my name you're being
ignorant this is why what you don't
believe what we teach so why are you
wasting your time that's why because
what you're teaching is false and I
think it leads you to Hellfire that's
what the Bible say the no it's not me
it's the Bible the Bible teaches that
you guys are showing a different gospel
people
there because you guys are disbelievers
you're just as lost to the Muslims if
not more cuz you're even using the Bible
uh get Isaiah bro Isaiah chapter one you
see like you you guys come out with the
boldness man I I talk to them they run
too book of
Isaiah yes you're running you're not
you're not engaging you're not engaging
every weekend for 3 hours so let's
engage I'm here how am I running away so
look I came from Vegas I heard I heard
that you hear me out hear me out hear me
out hear me out I heard that you were
here I said oh the oh the Israelites are
here okay cool let me go down there and
talk to them because we had a good
conversation the first time remember but
you didn't believe okay so that so that
so I'm here for another conversation
about the scriptures you just want man
you just want cloud and [__] no we not
Cloud I already have that dude I don't I
don't need you guys for that I already
have the cloud I'm I'm Vindicated in the
Lord I'm here for you to plant the seed
for you concerning Judah Judah is Right
Here Right so- called black judah's here
right J the of so let's get another
scripture and heia king of Judah here
all Heaven we're going to get another
scripture see what the scripture say
Lord has spoken I have nourished and
brought up children say about isit re
against me the ox knowth his owner and
the ass is Master's criis yeah so these
are simple animals go ahead but Israel
do not know let's see here my people do
not consider yeah so our people don't
consider man a sinful Nation a people
landed with iniquity a seed of evildoers
childr that are corrupted y they have
forsaken the Lord they have provoked the
holy amazing amazing amazing they are
gone we're about to see what the
scriptures say why should you be tricken
anymore evil Revolt more and more the
whole head is sick head is sick man sick
they're curs they don't even know who
they are they still call themselves you
don't know who you are man it's talking
about you right we know we're the
Israelites we're God's chosen people but
a lot of our you're judging with a with
a with a log in your eye my brother look
man what just walk away why would I do
that here cuz
I don't want you here man because I'm
going to I'm I'm I'm confounding you to
with the I'm not in your face or
anything I'm confounding you with the
word of God you can't handle the word of
God you can't handle the scripture you
don't want to deal with the scripture
bro you don't want to deal with the
scripture break lo you don't you don't
want to deal with the scripture about to
start so we're dealing with the
scripture and you have no answers for
your faith oh he was about to break
loose you got Jak here trying to debate
you have no reason for your belief none
you got so let's go ahead I'm going go
to get get we going to get Colossians 3
man let's goe to get Colossians 3 man I
go teach that over there man I'm going
teach it right here to you you need to
hear you try to like build upon another
man's Foundation you need to hear who
whose Foundation Foundation you don't
have a foundation here bro you're not
standing on nothing you don't stand on
Christ the lord is supposed to be the
rock you stand on you don't stand on
nothing bro that's what I'm saying I'm
trying to bring you over to the truth to
the gospel The Book of John you have a
false gospel man there was a division
you have a false gospel the Bible says
if you're teaching another gospel you're
a cursed of them said he had a devil in
his man you're a cursed and I fear for
you man it's funny cuz he call us a
devil that's the simp yeah you're the
devil you're the devil you're an
antichrist M fact what do you what do
you believe about the Messiah you
believe he's created the Jews do you
believe that Jesus is created and many
of them said he had a devil see he's the
word of go he's the word of God that you
desay you're an antichrist you deny him
yeah you are you deny him you deny the
gospel many of them you deny the gospel
mad why are you denying the
gospel watch let's goad and get this
verses out y'all let's go and get this
verses out look look at them say what am
I again your [__] Bro Look at
that will open the look man we laugh in
the face of Satan man we we laughing the
S we laugh in the face of Satan we laugh
in the face of Satan your lord is your
lord is dead your lord is dead your lord
is dead your lord is dead Yahweh the
king he has the true gospel and the
truth and he destroyed this false gospel
a long time time ago this false Gospel
of race you don't know anything about
the scripture my brother but it's okay
you can be of your father the devil I'm
here to bring you out I'm here to plant
the seed come out from your father the
devil with with that white supr come
come out come out that white Su come out
of there let man let's go ahead and see
let's see what the scriptures say man
let's see what the scriptures say this
is Colossians 3: 11 you trying to be
like Israelite this is Colossians
chapter 3 here it is Spirit but now you
must put them all away on
wrath malice the word of God is being
read out man speak the word of God is
being read out man why y'all talking
through the word of God let's walk over
here yeah don't yeah run away run away
run away run away this is crazy run away
we're just here to edify you're not
edify anything you're not here to
edify I'm here to edify you we don't
need you to edify yes you do cuz you
don't know the word of God don't need
that you do between us and God but no
you're already under condemnation bro
just walk away you're already under
condemnation
I I I I'll read this I'll read this
first I'll read this I'm going read this
I'm going read this I'll read this and
I'll be done we're being very patient
you man yeah I'm going to read this I'll
be done okay read it and just step man
all right for sure for sure I'll read
this I'll be done okay so it says but
now you must put away put them all away
anger okay right what you guys are under
yes oh yes oh at least he is at least he
is at least he is put this away and S up
yeah but you sinning bro you you cussing
me out calling me on my name
disrespectful you angry you sinning in
keep going go ahead go ahead do your
thing all right appreciate it appreciate
it okay anger wrath
malice right slander what you were just
doing earlier just now a few seconds ago
slanderous time apologize man sorry by
all good all good an obscene talk from
your mouth all that you was just
practicing just now my brother do not
lie to one another seeing that you have
put off the old self with its practices
and you have put on the new self you're
right man right blessing cannot come out
of your mouth that the blessing and
curses can't come out the same MTH right
you was just cursing me all right and
then it says um and having and have put
on the new self which is being renewed
in knowledge after the image of its
creator here there is not Greek or Jew
right circumcised and uncircumcised
Barbarian cian slave or free but Christ
is all and in all so that was the
message that I came here to show you
guys man all right brother Christ is all
in all
repent believe in the gospel all right
man all right thank you you're welcome
all right thank you very
[Applause]
much and that ladies and gentlemen is
how you handle the Hebrew Israelites the
second that somebody comes knowing the
scripture they're going to cow away just
like the Muslims just like Jehovah's
Witnesses just like atheists it's no
different the Antichrist spirit is the
same spirit and they can never stand up
against the gospel oh my God logic
[Music]